[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter good day martin i was
waiting for you to maybe
chip in i have capitulated
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
are you well i'm okay that's good
let's carry on and open with a word of
prayer
our heavenly father we are once again
back here and we ask that you enlighten
our minds again
and there are many things that we have
to discuss that
many people wonder about so we ask that
you give us
insight and also bless the viewers with
insight from the holy spirit in jesus
name amen
amen
now martin
if we don't answer questions
then people become concerned
so every now and then we do have one
where we
answer some questions
and
i think it's important that we answer
questions every now and then what's nice
when you answer the questions is
sometimes it also a question can become
a little bible study and become yes and
become something that
that is not only informative to the
viewers but to ourselves too
because you know
we are just fallible human beings
the word of god is infallible
and we try our best
and under prayer we try and see if we
can
put all the pieces together
is there any biblical quote
with regards to wearing a cross
the answer is no
there's no biblical
quote
there are indications
that god's people should remove external
adornments
we have many cases like that where
the children of israel
went through processes
where they removed their jewelry
now there's nothing per se wrong with
jewelry
it is what it achieves in the minds
that can be problematic you know the
women of zion are
haughty
they wear bangles around there this
their hair is braided etc etc
that is not the problem the problem is
the haughty bit
so when it comes to
correcting some of these issues of
personality god has seen fit in the past
to tell them to remove their jewelry
and whenever they were
on the road towards idolatry then we
also find
that he asked them to remove their
jewelry
jacob is a nice example when he was on
his way to esau
he dug a hole under the terrapin tree
and they cast their jewelry in there so
the makeup was gone
they went through a car wash
and they met him they met him without
external adornments he had to look at
them for face value
and judge by their character
so is the emblem of the cross good or
bad i hear some claiming the t is for
tamus
i also also heard people claiming christ
was crucified on a tree or a stake and
not a cross
and that it amounts to an idol because
wearing jewelry is forbidden
when the servant of abraham went to
find a wife for isaac
and when he found her
he put a nose ring on her and he gave
her jewelry
as as a
symbol so
when we are
looking at the beings in heaven every s
every precious stone was your adornment
it says of lucifer
so the problem doesn't lie in
the jewelry the problem lies in the
effect that the jewelry can have well
look at me you know
i'm something special and uh
i have all this value attached to me and
it makes for
the possibility
of self-exaltation
and we know that many people adorn
themselves in order to exalt themselves
in one way or another
or claim
superiority over others
so
this is what it's all about so the
actual item is not the problem
the cross
is it also a symbol in luciferian
worship the sign of tammuz the answer is
yes
but so is the rose martin
in the rosicrucian order the rose is a
symbol of lucifer
now who created the rose guarded god
so may i not give a rose to my wife
no
or may i you may okay if i get all
tangled up and say oh the rose is a
symbol of lucifer i'm not going to give
it to her. you know what
he's a thief and a liar from the
beginning he stole the rose emblem from
god
so if i ignore him and i look at the
rose and i say this is a beautiful
creation and i'm going to give it
to the one that i care about
there's nothing wrong with that
so again
there are symbols that have luciferian
symbols attached to them and there are
symbols that are religious in nature you
can take many of them for example the
fish
[Music]
is being used as a symbol of
christianity right
but the fish the sign of dagon is also a
symbol of lucifer
so
which one are you doing depending on
whose will you are doing yeah
whether you attach a value to the one
symbol or to another symbol
but the bible also says do not create
stumbling blocks
that's a
good point because what i wanted to ask
now is
is it not safer
to rather
not go that way to
bring about yes
now we do not need a symbol the symbol
that that god looks for is a contrite
heart
so i do not need a symbol to advertise
what i am
[Music]
the character should speak for itself
now
if i want to wear a cross to show that i
am a christian
but i behave like a worldling
which is the case in many many cases
right
then that cross becomes not only a
symbol of oh that man is a christian
but some people will look at upon it and
say those hypocrites hypocrites
so is it better to wear one or better
not to wear one if you decide to wear
one
what are you going to wear are you going
to wear a wooden one
are you going to wear a silver one are
you going to wear a gold one are you
going to wear a big one are you going to
wear a small one
and if you're very very
ardent about your opinion you might want
to wear a big cross
inside of your shirt outside of it yeah
yeah so do do many of the priests and
prelates wear crosses like that
huge ones right
and then you find out
what they sometimes do in darkness
and the news meter media reports it
and
then the name of
christ
is maligned
i mean the word christian is a very
beautiful name
because it means that you are
representing christ how do you represent
him by a symbol no by your fruits okay
is there a possibility
that the symbol eventually can become an
article of reverence
yeah definitely is it happening in
churches well
all religions have symbols yes so
wouldn't this just become like you said
another one
even if it's in christianity all right
so some will look upon the symbol and
we'll revere it
others will look upon the symbol and
despise it
some will locate it with a question mark
in their minds
so what is the best way to go forward my
personal opinion is i don't need a
symbol to advertise what i stand for i
agree with you on that one i think it's
better that your actions show it
than you adorning yourself with
something to show it yes and then was it
a poll
was it a stake
or was it a cross
well do we have any
biblical
answers to that i think we do because
jesus said to peter
when you are old
you will stretch forth your hands
in other words he was going to be
crucified
which he was
and that seems to indicate that it was a
cross
and not a stake
now what is the
stake made of or what is the cross made
of it's from a tree
now when you think about that martin
who's the author of life
god and god is right
did god know
which tree
was going to bury his son yes
he knew
did he take care of it that it would
grow into a sturdy tree yes in spite of
the fact that he knew that his son was
going to hang on it yeah
what does that tell you about the
character of god
it's amazing it's amazing
so let's let's just sum this up
uh there are many arguments
for or against placing a cross
within a church to advertise that you
are a christian church
your character should advertise that you
are a christian church that which you
stand for should
advertise that you are a christian
church
it's interesting
when protestantism came into the world
they removed all symbols
and
it is interesting that in the early
stages
of protestantism before the protestant
movement under the times of huss for
example
they were ordered to remove all symbols
they were only allowed to preach
but they were not allowed to have any of
the symbols because catholicism claimed
them all yeah
and that was such a magnificent thing to
happen because all they had to rely on
was the word of god
it is true and the word of god is
powerful and penetrates through to the
marrow and it makes it pure
if you don't have anything
obscuring the message yes and then if
you take
the church in england
that removed all the images they were
gone
and they had a pure word of god
and under under that
ambiance the word of god the king james
bible everything was given to the world
and then the oxford movement came
how did the oxford movement start what
was the first thing they did
bring back the images okay
bring back the cross
bring back a little statue here bring
back the candles
eventually bring back images of mary
eventually bring all those things back
to distract the mind and where are they
today
back
totally
um under catholicism they're back to the
middle ages yeah they're back
so
martin
you know what let the word of god do the
talking
and let's leave the symbols for those
that need crutches in their christianity
very good i agree thanks
okay
can you please explain what's wrong
with what jehovah's witnesses believe
there are a lot of people in that
denomination who are loving people but
they should see the truth for what it is
martin there are a lot of people
in
all denominations
that are lovely people
and the bible says come out of her
my people
so that means his people are in
other denominations even
come out of her if you're not in a
denomination if you're not in a church
he wants you to join his church yes
and also
this does not just refer to those that
claim
a christian background
it
cuts across the board to every religious
system in the world because
there is a longing in the soul
which god has placed in humanity
which cannot be filled by anything other
than christ
i've come across them in every
single
religious system
in the world
from shamanism
to the major
abrahamic religions
there is
a gap
in your psych
that can only be filled by christ
now any religion
that makes christ less than he is
is a problem
if we do not recognize that jesus christ
is fully god
then we have missed the point of the
plan of salvation
then he has sent a proxy
god has sent a proxy to take care of the
situation
god is not a coward
god is not someone that hides behind
proxies
god is someone who steps onto the plate
himself
and in the beginning was the word
and the word was with god
and the word was god
is one of the most profound sentences in
the bible
another one is
where we find
on numerous occasions people falling at
the feet of jesus and worshiping him
without rebuke
whereas anybody else even an angel would
rebuke such an action
we find it in revelation we find it
everywhere
where
an angel rebukes someone who falls down
to worship them
i'm a fellow servant they say
but not in the case of christ
in him was all the fullness of the
godhead
bodily
he was in the fullest sense god
now jehovah's witnesses
remove the deity of christ
and that is
a major
major problem
also jehovah's witnesses
have a problem with the law
[Music]
the law of ten commandments you break
one you break them no
all
so you have all of those ideas in there
as well sunday keeping
in other words regarding papal laws
rather than biblical laws
the major major problem with jehovah's
witnesses
is that they
minimize
jesus christ
and in order to achieve that
they have their own bible version
and that bible version when it came out
for the first time
created a massive furore
amongst the christian world
and if you think about it martin
that bible version
that jehovah's witness bible version has
fewer changes in it than the niv yeah
but let's just leave it at that
otherwise we get into another topic
any religion
that makes christ
less than he is
is not from god absolutely and that's
the main answer if that's the case
you mentioned before that
when you choose a church
you
first tick
a few things yes and if you
have that tick if
on you cannot you cannot associate
that's you don't even have to go further
to look for other truth that's the one
that says all right
most protestant denominations
acknowledge the deity of christ
right but they don't acknowledge his law
no all right
catholicism
denies the atonement christ never died
for you he was just an example
that is a major you don't have a savior
then then the church has to become your
savior and they have to
replace
the righteousness of christ
with sacramental rituals which is
pathetic
in my opinion
if you take any of the other major
religions they totally deny christ
in terms of his deity they might
acknowledge him as a prophet like islam
does
but they deny the sonship
if you take judaism
they deny his messiahship
and those that do accept him the other
messianic like the messianic jews are
looking for a national deliverer
and he never came as a national
deliverer he came as a deliverer from
sin
so all of them
categorize or place christ in a box that
suits them
if you do not accept
in the beginning was the word
and the word was with god
and the word
was god
all things were created for him and by
him and without him was not anything
created
if you do not accept that
you have a problem that's it you cannot
be part
of such a denomination
beautifully beautiful thanks
please address those of us that were
married but the partner left to marry
another
martin
this is
something which
is a common reality in the world today
it says further does the spouse that
finds his
herself without the spouse able to
remarry
another
now there are so many permutations to
this question
i don't know have you ever dealt with
issues like that yes i sat on a
committee
that dealt with this particular issue
jesus christ
made it quite plain
marriage is a
a bond which is supposed to be
for life
right
and
he said there were a few things
where
it was legal
to separate
and
one of them is infidelity of course
adultery
that was a legal reason to separate
there are many many verses in the bible
that deal with this issue now you know
if you are in the world and you are
not in christ
and you've been through a number of
divorces or one divorce or whatever
and then you come and you are married
and you find christ
then you suddenly realize that what you
had been doing in the past was wrong
you cannot undo that
so you have to accept that from the
moment that you
realized it was sin
then it is sin the time of ignorance god
winks at
right
in other words he oversees it because
you did not know
but if you know
and you do it not
then it be for you
sin
that's what the bible says
so marriage is a very very serious
commitment why
because it is a simple yep
it's a symbol of a greater commitment of
a greater
marriage yes
because we are also a bride
[Music]
and then we have a bright groom
and
that one is christ christ okay
the marriage of the lamb
so
that has to be an eternal arrangement
that can never be broken
because if it is ever broken
then that vow that covenant is made null
and void
so it's a very deep deep symbolism
now marriage is also a crucible
[Laughter]
and it is designed to change your
character
from selfishness to
unselfishness
which is what a very hard character
tried to give up right
definitely
many marriages actually look quite happy
because one person is dominant and the
other one is submissive
but eventually after a number of years
the submission becomes a bit of a pain
in the neck and something can happen
and to the great surprise of the
dominant party the other one wants to
leave
and
never they understand why
this is something that god wants us to
learn and it's so hard to learn
that many would rather change the shirt
that's why we have such a high divorce
rate
and the sad thing is
that the divorce rate in the christian
community is not lower
than it is in the secular environment it
might even be higher
because there are other tensions which
come into play as well
so this is a major major problem
so please address
those of us that were married
but the partner left to marry another if
the partner left to marry another that's
adultery exactly so
it's one of the reasons why
you may marry again
so if the other party has married again
then we assume that that marriage is
consummated therefore
in the eyes of
god it's adultery
now
as i say it depends on whether you knew
all of those circumstances so that's why
most churches have a committee
to
bash through this and see whether this
divorce is legitimate or whether it is
not legitimate
there are cases
when divorce is not legitimate
but because of certain circumstances
it is
probably wise to separate
until such time
as there is a change of heart so that
they can be a reconciliation
the point of it is god wants to change
the character
and he wants us to
submit to his softening
impulse
any form of coercion
any form of
dominance
is something that will destroy
any relationship including marriage
so
yes there are circumstances when you may
marry again and there are circumstances
where you have to separate which is very
hard
reconciliation is possible
if
self is crucified
and it's one of those things that every
one has its own merits so it's not a one
answer for all correct it's a very
difficult situation but i think we have
addressed it as far as we can
can you please explain these texts they
are totally different in versions other
than the king james
psalms 8 verse 5
for those made him a little lower than
the angels and has crowned him with
glory and honor
and if you read in the rsv the same
verse thus made him a little less than
god
and does crown him with glory and honor
now
both of them are actually correct
because the word angels there is elohim
which can refer to the angelic host
but is also a term applied to god
so when it says thus made him a little
lower than the angels you can say you
have made him a little lower than god
himself
and again it's a question of who you are
addressing as to which one of the two
you would use in this particular case
both are correct
but i would say
that if you said
a little lower than god it would not be
incorrect
when it comes to isaiah 10 1 israel is
an empty vine
he bringeth forth fruit unto himself
according to the multitude of his fruit
he has increased the altars recording
according to the goodness of his land
they have made goodly images
now the king james is
is very well
put it's it's uh
very to the point
it's almost poetic
so israel is an empty vine there's your
clue
in other words it's devoid of fruit
that's it
and the fruit that it does bring forth
it brings forth unto itself so it's it's
a very selfish fruit that it brings
forth
this nation that was put into the world
to be a light unto the world and draw
people to the truth
ensconced themselves in the idea that
they were the sole heirs of salvation
and that everybody else was
excluded this can also almost bring back
to what we've mentioned in the first
instance about the jewelry yes
the more empty
the more outside
adornment you need
so according to the
multitude of his fruit
he has increased the altars that's
another
fascinating
aspect of religious
thinking
the less you have
of the true
power of god within you
the more you need outward display
right the bigger the church have to has
to be the church has to be bigger the
paintings have to be more glorious the
the altar has to be decked with gold and
precious stones and that is the glory it
is
empty
it is vain
so if you if you look at some of the
christian churches or so-called
christian churches
god would be more happy to meet you
under a tree yeah
which in any case is a far more glorious
edifice than some of these
decked places so the emptier you are the
more you need to display
that's what they did and according to
the goodness of his land they have made
goodly images
so they make more and more images their
religion becomes an
external religion rather than a religion
of the heart and they are totally devoid
of fruit
now if you take the esv version
israel is a luxuriant vine that yields
its fruit
that in my opinion is the most pathetic
translation that you could possibly have
it's directly opposite it's exactly the
opposite the more his fruit increased
the more altars he built that's correct
yeah
as his country improved he improved his
pillars
that's pathetic again
so as far as i'm concerned
this verse here by itself would
disqualify it from
reading this version
finished
enough said and that's what we've said
if this
with like with the
jehovah's witness when you're looking
for churches if there's one tick that's
not
right
why do you still want to carry on with
it no discard it discard this bible put
it aside read that which makes sense
and if you if you study the context
martin
context alone which one of the two
must be correct
the first the first one obviously it's
it's the great catastrophe yeah of
of the religious systems of the world
the other one the second one is exactly
how it should not be it is exactly how
it should not be yes
this question is i've been watching many
of you and martin what's up prof
episodes and also total onslaught
etc it is most fascinating and
insightful and i thank you for your
efforts
i learned the protestant teachings and
doctrine many many years ago
but recently started questioning some of
the accepted doctrines and ideas taught
i am comparing the teachings to the sda
teachings i
like you
want the whole truth without assumption
when speaking with protestant taught
christians the well-trained ones
immediately brush off the sda concept
and the church as a cult
they do not deeply know the adventist
beliefs which took me a long time to
understand
i now understand the sabbath concept a
bit better my sister is jewish by choice
not marriage
and we discuss the jewish version of law
keeping as opposed to the sda or modern
sabbath-keeping versions
she says we gentiles are unable to keep
it as we need a support group just like
the thousands in the time of moses and
israel in the desert
i have some practical questions
regarding the sabbath please help with
insights
all right
if we look at this question
then this is one that affects anyone
who even
contemplates
looking at seventh-day adventism that's
why i think it's important that we
address some of this because like we've
mentioned with the jehovah's witness
there's a lot of people that are
comparing now the messages of these
churches yes all right so that is one
one aspect
why would you become a seventh day
adventist if you do not have to
i've always said if you become a seventh
day adventist
without good reason
you need your head red
you don't need a pasta you need a shrink
if you want the ire of the world upon
you
yes they will call you a cult
right
and then he has the the question here
about his jewish sister who has now
adopted the idea
that the gentiles
are outside of the covenant
and they have no idea whatsoever
we'll get to both of them all right
let's first go to adventist doctrines
modern adventist doctrines if you boil
them down to basics are not complicated
no actually i agree with you on 100 when
i was studying
i always thought before studying the
doctrines
also my mind was full of all negative
and all these cultish thinking about it
and when you start studying it
it's actually so
easy and biblical because it's just what
stands in the bible all right now
if you look at the various denominations
which one is probably
more despised than most others probably
the seventh adventist right
now
that's not a criteria to determine that
you want to become one but it's an
indication
that you perhaps should take a deeper
look
exactly because
the christian the disciples that church
was also not the most popular okay how
important if you take the old testament
was the law of god
it's pivotal pivotal right all right
the service of the sanctuary how
important was that
the whole system was based on was based
on that
did god
find it necessary to write his law down
with his own finger in stone
did he cast it in stone
all right were there curses and
blessings with regard to keeping it or
not yeah
and then god suddenly says you know what
i mean that's the hash of it let's get
rid of it now let's just put a line
through it
discard it forget it does that make any
sense no okay how important was the
sabbath in the old testament yeah you
read it in every
well also every so often you rejected
did jesus keep the sabbath oh yes as his
custom was did paul and the disciples
keep the sabbath as their custom was
they prepared spices on the preparation
day which was the friday they rested
according to the commandment
and on the first day of the week they
went again to carry on with their work
of anointing the body of christ which
was no longer there
so did they keep the commandment
even after christ's death yes did paul
preach on the sabbath to the jews yes
did he preach on the sabbath to the
gentiles yes
okay did god that created the sabbath
rest on the sabbath did jesus say
i have not come to abolish the law but
fulfill it not one jot or one tittle
will by any means disappear from the law
did he say that yeah
anyone who teaches others
you'll have a big problem right if you
love me keep my commandments he says he
loves me and keeps not my commandments
is a liar and the truth is not in them
here are they that keep the commandments
of god that they may have the right to
the tree of life
lest are they that keep the commandments
in revelation all right now if you take
the writings of paul
and you study them carefully
keep yourself from fornication keep
yourselves from idolatry honor your
parents you can go through them all
then the book of hebrews does he talk
about the sabbath and the issue of rest
hebrews 4. you're going to get rid of it
in the new testament you can't get rid
of it in the old testament so why would
you want to get rid of it
for yourself or ease for to justify some
certain action
that you are doing that is contrary to
what the bible says right
and you're either listening to another
religious system the papacy for example
or you find it convenient
but you have no biblical basis
for doing what you are doing
therefore
they will have to if they don't want to
give up their their pet they will have
to malign those that have given it up
for the sake of the word
so i'm a seventh day adventist
not because someone convinced me
but because the bible convinced me
that's it i'm the same you're the same
yeah all right
did you become a seventh-day adventist
because of ellen g white no
not at all i didn't even know about
or study at all i never knew about her
until after i was baptized me too i
became one on the basis of the bible and
the bible alone now cult
is
an organization
that has an extraneous
source of information other than the
bible
[Music]
now they will say we are a cult because
we also read the writings of ellen d
white
but in those writing it says we have no
creed except the bible yes so the bible
is the standard whereby every single
doctrine must be judged
that means everything that she wrote
must be judged by the bible
and if it is not in the bible
then
or not supported by the bible then you
have to discard it right yeah and it's a
false teaching to the lord to the
testimony does the world love alice
bailey and blavatsky yes do they love
ellen g white no ah
did they love the prophets in the past
or did they love the false prophets
loved the false prophets even the church
even the church didn't love the prophets
no nobody loved they stoned them right
so martin
i could just say to this person when you
study the doctrines of of the
seventh-day adventist church
study them in the light of the bible
if if they are substantiated then buy it
if they are not substantiated discard it
it's as simple as that that's it
and
no amount of talking
can change that concept no
but now obviously like she mentioned in
the end she's got a few questions
questions because
and and it is because
the crux of the matter obviously comes
back to the sabbath all right so let's
go to the jewish sister
we discuss the jewish version of the law
keeping
as opposed to sda or modern
sabbath-keeping versions
she says we gentiles are unable to keep
it as we need a support group
just like the thousands in the time of
moses and israel in the desert all right
now i had an interesting experience in
israel once
i've told it before but i it fits so
i'll tell it again
i was in israel and i was sitting at the
wailing wall
just outside the barrier
now normally the orthodox
jews will despise a gentile
they will often even cover their faces
not to be defiled by a gentile
but on this particular occasion there
were some
that had obviously met dire economic
times
and so
they thought
that i might have a little contribution
towards their
problem
which i was not unwilling to give
because i felt
i felt compassion for them
but i didn't want to give it without
first seeing if i could bring a
discussion point to the table
so i sat there and
this young jewish rabbi who had very
tatted clothes
came and sat down and he asked me
whether i had something and i said yes
i'll
gladly help you
but do you mind if i have a few
questions for you and so i started
talking about
issues in the bible
and i mentioned uh
you know
some of the rituals in the old testament
the law
and i wanted to bring him to the point
where we looked at some of the studies
in daniel unto messiah the prince you
know daniel chapters
8-9
and
he became very agitated
and i asked him what the problem was
and he said
you may not interpret the scripture
so i said why not
he says only the rabbis
may interpret the scripture and you have
to accept what the rabbi says as the
only interpretation
so i said but what if the interpretation
is contrary to what the word is saying
what do you do then
then you still have to accept what the
rabbi says
so this is a way of thinking in judaism
yeah you the the bible is not given for
you to read
it is given to the rabbi to interpret
now you find that same attitude in
catholicism exactly the priest
the priest is the one that's going to
interpret it for you
and once you decide to interpret it for
yourself you become the enemy of the
system yeah
it led to the inquisition
it led to the mass murder of billions of
people
and this is just just the way that it is
but god gave you a brain
and god gave you the word
and god holds you individually
responsibly and not corporately
irresponsible
the same applies to the seventh-day
adventist church
the adventist church may not interpret
the bible for me
the adventist church can tell me this is
how i see the bible how i understand the
bible and then when i study the bible
and i find harmony between that i can
accept it but if i do not find harmony i
have the perfect right not the duty
to reject it
because god has given me an
individuality
and i am responsible for my actions
towards him
not in the jewish system
you are responsible
to the rabbis interpretation in
catholicism you are responsible to the
priest to the priest in islam you are
responsible to the imam's interpretation
and that's it
right
so this is a major problem
the way in which you keep the law
is not determined by how the church
tells you to keep the law correct
the way you keep the law is determined
by how the word tells you to keep the
law exactly
now when it comes to the sabbath
jesus
broke with the customs of the jews yes
because they had made exacting laws as
to how to keep the sabbath
and jesus said
they're not in the word of god no and
therefore he ignored them exactly and
now that gets a misconception of he
broke the law no he broke the jewish
tradition
now if catholicism tells me i have to
keep the sunday
that is a catholic tradition yeah
and if the bible tells me i have to keep
the seventh day then i have to break
with that tradition and ignore it
will it
excite the ire
of
the priest and the prelay yes
absolutely
who's at fault
they are they were at fault because it's
not in harmony with the word of god
therefore they say the bible must be
interpreted in terms of tradition and
tradition is the context in which the
bible must be read no
tradition must be subject to the bible
yeah
otherwise
you must discard it as useless
as physical exercise profiteth little in
vain in vain they worship me teaching
for doctrine the commandments of men
so what does the bible say about sabbath
keeping martin
very little yeah
there's a few things
set in there and you have to fit all of
it you have to call the sabbath a
delight the lord stay honorable
do not neglect the assembly of the
saints
right
in other words make god first do not do
your own thing
do not go about your secular business on
the sabbath day it is a day of communion
with god but it must be called a delight
not a day of ceiling inspection
[Laughter]
although if you are very tired a ceiling
inspection might be quite warranted on
the sabbath day true
so
those are the issues that you have to
have to thrash out with the word of god
and with your conscience
and
the basis that you have to understand
is the sabbath is
based not on ritual no it's based on
relationship
and once you get that concept into your
mind
then you can compare it with any other
relationship if you want to strengthen a
relationship
time
what do you do you spend time with that
person
and in our busy schedule god has said
i've set
aside a block of time
if you want to share it with me then
do it that doesn't mean he's not
available on the other days when you are
married martin are you married
uh one day a week or seven days a week
non-stop
seven minutes
okay
and that's exactly that's a very good
point that you make
so it's not i'm for five days in this
relationship in the next
other two days that's exactly how god is
but
there's a special day in your
wedding yes let's put aside a time just
for us
okay let's leave it at that
all right then he has some very specific
questions if the sun sets light as it
does here in cape town or canada when
does the sabbath in each country start
an end from even to even shall your
sabbath be
sunset to sunset
that's it now there are many many
denominations and groups that make
different rules
but even to even so your sabbath be is
good enough for me yeah if it's in
iceland
and the sun is for three months just
bare not coming up or whatever
then there's still a time when it is
sunset and sunrise
yeah
i have a business that requires to me
requires me to work sometimes on
saturdays
it is unavoidable
how practically do i obey god's law in
this condition as
it is income lost if i do not work
sometimes on these days
that is a problem that most people are
faced with right
and there are certain things
and certain works that can be done on
the sabbath day
works that uh
are humanitarian in nature
is it jesus said is it lawful to do good
on the sabbath day
is it lawful to deal with the calamity
your animal has fallen into the ditch
can you take him out on the sabbath day
can you feed him on the sabbath day
there are certain jobs that have to be
done right
if somebody is sick do you stop nursing
them on a sabbath day
no
no so there are certain things that must
be done but if the work is of a secular
nature totally secular
then try and change it
that's it that's it that's all i can say
and you ask god to help you even if it
looks impossible yeah
and sometimes
maybe it's necessary to find a different
work that's it he'll show you the way if
you put your trust and
get up that relationship with him you
will know
i was informed by a sda acquaintance not
to be legalistic about this
so what can we do or not do on the
sabbath and what do i use as my guide on
this who determines the rules as we
don't wish to end up with excessive law
keeping like the orthodox jews again
correct
i think we've answered it it's about
relationship
does it build relationships to take a
stroll in the park or in the forest
or does it break it down
well there's also
it depends as well
if you do it to
have the relationship built up with god
then it will work but if you just want
to do it for entertainment's sake
then you've lost it again all right so
if you want to spend time with god in
nature
would you go on a strenuous hike or
would you rather go for a peaceful
uh stay in
an environment of nature yeah so
it's about relationship right you're
building relationship you want to you
want to talk to god you can talk to god
through nature
you can talk to god through his word
you can talk to god with and together
with other people
so
what builds the relationship that is the
basis of the question
now you have
the very common legalistic argument
is it lawful to go and do bird watching
on the sabbath
the answer to most for most people would
probably be yes because you can
appreciate the beauty
now is it lawful to put on flippers and
goggles and to look at fish on the
sabbath day
well people will say no because now
you're enjoying yourself you're swimming
yeah but i
are you supposed to be miserable on the
sabbath day or are you supposed to call
it a delight these are these are
questions where legalists could spend
days arguing exactly think
relationship
and if it's right in terms of
then let no man tell you your duty
that's it
if we are not to work on sabbath then
surely church going should not be
on the service that that means the
pastor and admin staff must work while
i'm attending the church
well paul actually addresses that
and he says that we work harder without
breaking the law on the sabbath day
because you're busy with the lord's work
yes you're busy with his
consecrated work
okay
so if you're a nurse and you're taking
care of a debilitated patient
if you have done it to one of the least
of these my brethren you have done it
unto me
it's part of your
part of your worship right
so
yes the pastor works harder i always
know when it's sabbath
because normally i work harder than any
other day that's it
but it is spiritual work
and that does not qualify as
sabbath-breaking
because the same was with
the
levites yes
my jewish sister says that it doesn't
quite count as work why not actually the
jewish sister is right
in in that particular case
in the event a global climate or forced
lockdown sundays as the mark of the
beast comes then surely sabbath is
protected still
as we were forced to worship the beast
on a sunday
what does the sabbath keeper do in order
to avoid sunday keeping and not worship
the beast in this event how do you
believe we defy the mock
in such an event okay let's think about
that
constantine made a sunday law
you may not work on the sunday
now
if you make a sunday law that you may
not work on the sunday
that's not a serious issue
it's a step in the wrong direction
that's because you are
enforcing a doctrine
that is not biblical
but it is not contrary
directly to god's command it is a human
law
but
when you make a law that you must work
on the saturday
[Music]
then you are making a law contrary to
the bible now the roman catholic church
has that law
because at the council of laodicea
they made a law which says
christians may not
judaise
they must work
on
the sabbath day the saturday
but the sunday
they must keep
that is a law directly contrary to god's
law
so the roman catholic
sunday law issue
is also an anti-sabbath law that's why
it is the mark of the beast
because they are saying you must honor
my authority
and not
god's authority okay and what about
forced
worship on sunday
well as soon as you force something
then it has lost its value entirely
the reason i'm asking is because i think
that we might see something like this
and we're going to have a lot of people
asking that question in the future
do you have a problem worshiping god on
a monday no
a tuesday no what about a wednesday no
what about a sunday same that's why i'm
asking
is that going to be a problem because
that will probably be linked in the
future to
the laws that will be coming for the son
for the mark of the bible
that might be the case any any coercion
any force
immediately attacks the issue of
relationship
you're immediately
on the side of the transgressor because
you cannot force a relationship again
it's what nebuchadnezzar did yes even
though he said the god of daniel has to
be worshipped that law is not right
because he's still
forcing you to do something in fact if
they force me to worship on a sunday
i will be forced to pray to my god
to prevent them from their causes so i
will be worshiping on the sunday in my
sphere
and not according to their sphere
they will never be allowed to control or
coerce
you in terms of your religious
convictions
all right martin again
you know if you want to
find a little bit of guidance again it's
always good to go the spirit of prophecy
so let's read
what is written here
i want to say a few words in reference
to the keeping of the sabbath
this time is god's time not ours
when we trespass upon it we are stealing
from god some say
i would keep the sabbath if everybody
else kept it
others say oh if it were convenient
i would keep the sabbath
we are not to fit the sabbath to our
convenience but we are to bring
ourselves to the sabbath and the holy
commandment
and when we make up our minds to do this
we can do it
but when we are continually studying our
convenience it never will be convenient
for us to keep the sabbath
that's just an axiom
that's a law and it's going to be that
way
god has given us the whole of six days
in which to do our work and he has
reserved only one for to himself
this should be a day of blessing to us a
day when we should lay aside all our
secular matters and center our thoughts
upon god in heaven
but while we worship god we are not to
consider this a drudgery isn't that what
we just say exactly
the sabbath of the lord is to be made a
blessing to us and to our children they
are to look upon the sabbath as a day of
delight
a day which god has sanctified and they
will so consider it if they are properly
instructed
the parents may take their children
outdoors to view god in nature they can
be pointed to the blooming flowers and
the opening buds the lofty trees the
beautiful spires of grass and thought
that god made all these in six days
and rested on the seventh day and
hallowed
thus the parents may bind upon their
lessons of instruction to their children
so that when these children look upon
the things of nature they will call to
mind the great creator of them all
their thoughts will be carried up to
nature's god back to the creation of our
world
when the foundation of the sabbath was
laid
and all the sons of god shouted for joy
such are the lessons to be impressed on
the minds of our children
oneness takes me back to my atheistic
years
to me everything was a product of
evolution
therefore i could mess with it
and i did
i mean in in the course of my work as
i've said many times
i've had to
kill many many animals for the sake of
dissection to show the students what the
anatomy is etc etc
for experimental work that i did
and the creature
was to me a commodity
when i discovered the creation account
when i discovered the sabbath
it became
a lesson of all yeah
i now look at a flower
or a plant
totally differently to what i looked at
it before if i look at plants for
example
and their nutritional value and the
variety that you get and the tastes and
the textures
then i can say
that was created for my pleasure
therefore i'm i can gratefully accept it
and and be in awe as to the dynamics of
how everything was put together in that
particular thing so actually you as a
scientist
got more value out of science when you
acknowledge that god was a creator
science jumped to me
to a level
unconceived before
we are not to teach our children
that they must not be happy on the
sabbath
that it is wrong to walk out of doors oh
no christ let his disciples out by the
leg side on the sabbath day and taught
them his sermons on the sabbath were not
always preached with enclosed walls
we should seek to make the sabbath of
the lord honorable i believe the reason
why so many of our people are in
darkness
is because they treat the sabbath
lightly they do not regard it with the
sacredness that they should
why says one
can we not take the sheep out of the pit
on the sabbath day yes
but it seems in many cases that they let
matters run until more of this kind of
work is done than need really be
we are to honor god by observing his
sabbath not taking the only time that he
has sanctified and blessed
and set apart for himself and
appropriate this to our own use
so it's a day that you spend with god
you can
spend it in nature you can read you can
study the word you can converse about
god's things
if you do that you must actually be with
people that believe in god
because
it gets difficult
when
you are with secular orientized people
all right may you evangelize on the
sabbath yes
absolutely definitely
so she repeats here
many say that they would keep the
sabbath if it were convenient to do so
but this day is not yours it is god's
day
and you have no more right to take it
than you have to steal my purse
god had reserved it sanctified and
blessed it and it is your duty to devote
this time to his service
to make it honorable to call it a
delight
there are among the many assembled here
small children don't let these children
when you come to the meeting be left to
play about the grounds it is not right
let the children understand that this is
the sabbath of the lord
this is sacred time
you can give them excellent lessons upon
the subject bring your children to
christ that the mothers brought them
anciently
let us remember
these afflicted ones christ healed the
withered hand upon the sabbath day
he wrought on the right hand and on the
left on the sabbath day
let us humble our hearts before god and
he will come in and work abundantly for
us
there are those who profess to be
sabbath keepers who are letting the
banner trail in the dust
we want to be setting our hearts right
before god we do not want to be
conformed to the world
we do not want to link the hands of our
children with worldlings
yet at the same time we want to be kind
and courteous to all to have christian
politeness
that we may win all possible to take
their sacred stand on the platform of
eternal
so what can i say
that
your relationship with god
will often be reflected in the way that
you keep the sabbath definitely that's
one of the
um
easiest ways to see if your fruit is
carrying your relationship all right now
if you are trying to reach others and
you are harsh and judgmental and
legalistic about the sabbath will you be
very successful no
then you will be like the pharisees and
sadducees that wanted to keep the
sabbath according to their laws and
anything that jesus did was seen as
breaking the law okay
well what will attract people kindness
or harshness
what attracted them to jesus
his humbleness
okay let's finish this quote
while we are associated with unbelievers
we want to be a blessing to them we
should not act as they act and dress as
they dress we need to stand in that
position
where we shall have our conversation in
heaven from whence we look for the
appearing of our lord and savior jesus
christ
now when we read that statement we
should not act like they act nor dress
like they dress
that doesn't mean you have to be
so prim and proper that you stand out
like a sore thumb yeah you don't have to
be somber in your dressing style and
no
but you must be you must have a certain
modest decorum because you can be neat
and what you wear on the sabbath is not
what you wear in your your daily
activity
so you're sending a certain message on
the sabbath day and the message is quite
personal sometimes
when i first attended the adventist
church i had been used to doing
my own thing
jeans and
t-shirts that was my thing
they still are my thing yeah
but i went to church like that and i saw
all of these stuffed shirts in their
suits and in their
in their ties and i said
never will i do this i'm so rebellious
just like i am that is what everybody
has to be satisfied with and that's the
way it's going to be
and then one day
i came into conflict with
the university because i was no longer
willing to teach evolution
and so i was called into the rectorate
and i thought to myself whoa what am i
going to wear
why not your i'm not going to go in
there i'm not going to make a good
impression with my jeans and my t-shirt
so
i thought i better put on a suit
i didn't possess a suit at that stage in
my life
so what did i do martin i went and
bought one i went and bought one
and i put this stupid suit on and felt
like a stuffed shirt
and stated my case with the rectorate
it changed my entire life after that
and then when i went to church again i
was suddenly struck by the idea that i
am extremely hypocritical
for an earthly ruler
and that just the head of a university i
went and purchased the suits
but for the king of the universe i said
jeans and t-shirts will be fine for you
so i made a personal decision that on
the sabbath day
i will honor him also with my dress
and some people
only see me in in a church set up and
they think that that's what i wear in
the rest of the week
they haven't seen my hat
that keeps the sun out i have to i can
acknowledge yeah i think a bird will
find a
happy nest in it
but uh
it's a personal issue
and it's a sign of respect
we do not expect that the world will
appreciate our reasons for the
strictness upon the sabbath day
john says behold what manner of love the
father has bestowed upon us that we
should be called the sons of god
therefore the world knoweth us not
because it knew not him quoting 1 john 3
verse 1 and so
while the world may not appreciate our
views
we know that this was the course pursued
towards the majesty of heaven the king
of glory who clothed his divinity with
humanity
and came down to our world that he might
elevate the human race from their
degradation
john declares that the world knoweth us
not because it knew him not
is there anything in this quote that we
have read that is not in harmony with
scripture no this is 100 in harmony with
scripture and
i believe
if you you can find how to keep the
sabbath in what we've said in this
message basically there's nothing you
can add
well martin i think the sabbath question
is a good one to end our question and
answer session we will have
further ones in the future
and there are still many questions that
people have so let's ask god for his
blessing thank you
heavenly father
indeed
the pivot
around which the argument of
worship revolves will be the sabbath
question
it was a pivotal point in the entire old
testament times
it is a pivotal point in the times that
we are living in now as well
because it's not a question of a day
it's a question of worship
so help us to understand
this issue
so that we may bring it across in a way
which will be enlightening to people
and that they will understand
that it is linked to the issue of
worship
bless us as we go our various ways and
we thank you in jesus name amen
[Music]
you